hello and welcome to quad Riga Trump and
Europe partners or rivals that's our
title today on quad Riga Europe is still
reeling from the shock as a candidate
Donald Trump had bashed NATO criticized
Europe and Angela Merkel so what can be
expected now what's next in his victory
speech Donald Trump stone was more
conciliatory he pledged to be a
president for all Americans and told the
world community that he plans to seek
common ground with all countries saying
he wants partnership not conflict is
this a new Trump and that's what we want
to talk about with three people who
follow transatlantic relations very
closely and have been watching this
election and it's aftermath it's a
present for a pleasure to welcome Susan
Nieman she's a u.s. American philosopher
and head of the Einstein forum based in
potsdam and she says I'm reluctant to
make fascist comparisons Trump's victory
is extremely frightening Europe must now
take on the responsibility for
democratic and social values Stefan quiz
civic is a lawyer and a German American
political consultant who was a member of
the Republican Party he has left it he
says an evil aging clown and yellow
haired fascist apprentice has been
elected 45th president if we're here to
see the world in four years time it will
surely have become unrecognizable and
andreas clute covers Germany for the
Economist he says Trump's victory
presents a huge risk for the world
European leaders should try to contain
the worst instincts by making plans for
their own security without America Susan
let me start out by asking you about the
connection between Trump and evil
because your most recent and widely
praised book is called evil in modern
thought and it describes the question
posed by evil as this how can human
beings behave in ways that's so
thoroughly violate
both reasonable and rational norms by
that description would you call Donald
Trump evil absolutely it's not by the
way my most recent book but there's a
new edition that that came out last year
I think he violates well the interesting
thing about Trump if one likes is that
he has no norms that are recognizable he
cares literally about gold it's
interesting it's not just money it's
gold one has no evidence other than he
also likes blonde long-legged large
breasted women that also seems to be
connected with gold he seems to care
about nothing else whatsoever it's an
absence of any moral compass I stephy
pacifica you were a member of the
Republican Party you have left it and as
I understand it you did not vote in this
election but I have to ask you by not
voting at all didn't you helped to pave
the way for a victory biometry well the
thing with this with this election is
that there was no real choice and if we
look at many Republican voters or
potential Republican voters they had a
hard time choosing as well and you're
right about leaving the party and I did
so without delay after Trump was elected
I never endorsed him in any in any way
and can't do that in the long run I'm
not I basically did that heavy heartedly
because I'm not prepared to take
questions on him in the future okay you
will have to take a few questions here
but as an observer understood the
pollsters and the media got it very
wrong when it comes to trump and one
could even go further and say that with
our 24 seven coverage of Trump we helped
give him free publicity that may have
perhaps supported his rise to power
what's your reaction to all of this are
you doing a bit of soul searching even
as a journalist well I think the
Economist was not the medium in which
that dead
took was part of his rise I think that
was more of the television networks but
you're absolutely right and in fact you
were kinder than you needed to be we got
it wrong as a media elite for the second
time in a couple of months the first one
was brexit and did those are in some
ways comparable comparable because i
think in both cases it is true that we
as a cosmopolitan elite and as media
intellectuals seem to be blind to large
parts of the various countries in the
West that I suppose we don't get out to
enough or maybe that that don't want to
open themselves up to us and we keep
getting it wrong so it's it's there's
reason for to do a lot of soul-searching
Stefan Pacific to what degree do you see
the Republican Party itself as an
enabler people like the speaker in the
House of Representatives Paul Ryan did a
lot of twisting and turning try to hold
on to those core voters who were
supporting Trump while at the same time
not alienating moderate voters but would
you say that they were also facilitators
of what you clearly feel is a rise to
power by someone who is similar to a
fascist I do not I do not I mean Paul
Ryan is the last person I would I would
really blame or lots of Congress people
I I see the main the main enabling
factor with with the party itself with
the party apparatus that name named
namely the the Chairman Reince Priebus
who rallied we had quiet quite a few
conversations with with Republicans on
over the place before the elections anta
there was clearly something that meant
rallying that meant soldiering on behind
Trump and i found this wrong right from
the start but ryan was one of those no
you haven't talked to previous probably
know i have talked to either of them
Ryder didn't however fellow what they
did yeah yeah of course no I don't there
was a you know there were brief condom
Nations every time he crossed another
red liar but no one disavowed him
and there I have to agree with Melinda a
bit um it was a bad choice but it's not
true that there was no choice you know I
my son who bitterly my kids were Sanders
supporters as was i was raging the night
of the election why must I live in a
world in which there's no better choice
than this but he bit the bullet and he's
you know making various metaphors is it
apocalypse or apocalypse without or you
know whatever he did vote as many people
finally did vote for Hillary with
distaste but because the stakes were
extremely high and that was true of many
young people many older people you know
and if one looks at the percentage of
people who went for a third party much
less those who just didn't show up one
would see that this could have been
averted clearly at any rate many of us
posters media politicians normal
citizens clearly we underestimated the
level of disaffection and anger rage on
both sides of what is proven to be a
very very bitter divided we are hearing
voices of rage now from protesters in
streets across the u.s. protesting
against Trump's victory and clearly
showing that they now feel it's not
their country that they recognize in
this election Susan Nieman can you
understand those protesters when you see
people going out on the streets or would
you say hey this is not the peaceful
transition to an elected representatives
that that represents our democracy at
its best I understand them so well that
I've decided after many many years of
living in Germany to apply for German
citizenship because I would like to be a
European I feel that the United States
in this election has absented itself
from the core values that are important
to me so I do understand them I felt
and I'd be there myself if I were there
I felt that both Obama's and Clinton
statements were a noble plea no civil
war please because everyone was talking
about that in particular the Trump
supporters were talking about bringing
out their guns if the election went the
other way so that was a plea and I
suppose civil war is not an option but I
completely understand anyone who wants
to say this is not a democracy this is
not the America that I know and cherish
and as good a topic is Trump and Europe
so one has to ask this polarization that
we are witnessing in the u.s. those
protests on the streets the angry angry
voices of the Trump supporters are they
relevant for Europe or would you say
this is a domestic political problem
that the US needs to try to get a grip
on but frankly it's not something that's
directly a problem for Europe itself I
think it's very relevant furor because I
think there are several overlapping
themes that we're seeing this year
polarization has mainly been an American
thing it comes out of a two-party system
here in Germany for instance and a lot
of European parliamentary democracy with
many parties it's been there's been no
polarization so far if anything
political power is one in the middle
with grand coalition's of the sort that
we're seeing but because there was so
much of it here and that left room on
the fringes for this kind of
polarization on the street that you're
seeing and and I think we're input
usually America from everything blue
jeans onward was about ten years ahead
and most social trends and we seem to be
importing that to Europe and it's now
here so we have piggy des marchés we
have alternative for Germany i think in
france they're well ahead poland hungary
all around us austria and so on the
streets are polarized the politics here
isn't yet although it's becoming that
because we have populists fringes now
they just haven't had a very care
is matic representatives yet in Germany
in as America has been Trump and Sanders
but it's just a matter of time before
they get those and then the polarization
will enter politics as well stefan twist
of it you referred to this charismatic
representative in the US i think as a
yellow-haired clown or faction aging
yellow-haired clown and a fascist
apprentice if i'm not mistaken so
probably I scalish need to pose the
question but nonetheless he gave quite a
conciliatory concession quite a
conciliatory victory speech he used all
the right words talked about the
peaceful transition of power being
president for all Americans so I would
have maybe see a different Donald Trump
emerge from this someone who can heal
those divisions I don't really see this
I would have liked to see him giving a
conciliatory concession speech for that
matter but no he thought he basically
did that looked pretty much scripted
that's one thing totally and it's like a
raincheck I thought that might well be
but secondly it is that he did one of
the the basics of being a member of any
kind of Western society I mean if
somebody got their birthday I would go
congratulate and give them a present and
about ninety-nine point nine percent of
people are bring my condolences if
something happened that was very normal
I mean it was the least to be expected I
don't see this as a as a pattern for his
behavior I was simply following a
convention and nothing more basically
yeah someone else wrote for him that he
managed to read out without making
mistakes and that nothing in his past
suggests that he takes seriously the
point about the peaceful transition
Melinda you know I've been wondering
about the following and I none of us
really know what's about to happen but
why is it do Democrats why are Democrats
who is the one who give in to a peaceful
transition just like in two thousand
Hillary's still won the popular vote you
know this is he does not have a popular
majority and yet no one is raising any
questions about how someone whom every
serious political leader has said is no
not qualified by either knowledge
curiosity what character to aspire to
this kind of an office and nobody's
everybody's you know the the the
Democrats are all saying oh well it's
not rile up the country just as Gore did
in two thousand and I wonder i want to
bring us back to trump and europe but
let me let me just ask you this because
all of you are making some pretty dire
statements in regard to trump and his
potential to stir things up andreas clue
do you see him as somebody who
single-handedly could deconstruct
american democracy because of course
that is very relevant to America's
friends and allies well there are sort
of two aspects to to him now that he's
in office one is domestically in America
are the checks and balances is the
constitution of Hamilton and Madison
strong enough to contain a Caesar that's
what they had in mind when they drafted
is there will be populist and out of
that will come a Caesar and we have to
be ready for that so if the system will
be tested I think that in America the
system is strong enough the other the do
you remember that an American president
doesn't have as much power as outside of
America you would think inside of
America he does have a lot of power
outside of America and foreign policy
and there the it's much more interesting
and I I thought it was very good what a
foreign minister Steinmeier of Germany
said on television yesterday the real
issue there the danger is that we have
no idea what he's gonna do because
frankly I think he's never thought about
foreign policy seriously in his life
until now and one of the memes that's
been going around since yesterday among
us in the media elite browbeating
ourselves is we took him literally but
not seriously where where as his voters
took him seriously but not literally and
so now I'm wondering and I think that's
true but now if we're not if we're
supposed to sit here and not take
anything he said literally and I think
he is a clown and a lot of he says
things for effect maybe doesn't mean him
that includes probably his his
acceptance is acceptance speech
yesterday that still means we have no
idea what
would do I think he's easily provoked it
comes down to temperament but he has no
as far as we know conceptual framework
for how to approach foreign policy or
Europe so let's see if we can read a few
of the tea leaves we have a short report
at least on some of what we might expect
when it comes to foreign policy if we do
take him literally let's take a look on
NATO Donald Trump would not necessarily
back NATO allies those who do not
contribute to the Alliance should not
expect support from the US on Syria
Trump has promised to bomb Isis
militants and has also called for
sending in ground troops but he has no
plans to go after Assad
on the world economy Trump is against
free trade and beliefs foreign
competition is bad for the US economy
the plan european american trade deal t
tip will have little chance on climate
change Trump does not believe in global
warming he plans to withdraw from the
Paris agreement and his relationship to
Germany Trump considers Chancellor
Angela Merkel a disappointment he has
called her stance on Europe's
immigration crisis a disaster the
question is will he implement his
controversial agenda so Stefan Pacific
take the first stab at that question
will he implement those things that we
just saw all of them mentioned in his
so-called basic speech on foreign policy
that he gave at the end of last spring
as a candidate but you've all said he's
a clown he may not mean what he says
what do you think he would do what do
you think he wouldn't do well I presume
that he has some basic ideas whether
their policy led or not but at least you
might have made up his mind what he
wants so probably these things as
building the wall to Mexico to Mexico
that is yeah talking or even negotiating
with Putin on a on a brotherly level how
do do I put that these things will
happen and everything trade
globalization that was a huge part of
his campaign would you expect him to
really begin something like a great lots
of lots of people lots of people say he
he believed of all people was was one
who killed t tip now that that might
well happen transatlantic trade greater
yeah so that this is not going to pass
so that that's quite an interesting
aspect as regards the leftist activists
in Europe who didn't want to have it now
they have somebody who who put it away
for them or did away with it so that
might happen what else is doable
particularly as regards Asia China for
that matter I'm not too sure whether he
can contain
in US trade in a way that he uh yeah he
really got the village perspective on
that and this clip what's the economist
saying about it do they think we will
really see now an era of protectionism
and trade war beginning with under a
president Trump well again we don't know
how literally did take him but i think i
agree i mean-- certain things from his
point of view are either low hanging
fruit given that he has a republican
congress to work with which Obama never
did domestically that would be to repeal
Obamacare they're gonna get together
they're gonna do that I think on trade
and on the Mexican wall he's brought
that up so much that that he has no way
out he has to show them something other
one on a lot of other things that would
have been exactly in trade not signing
the transatlantic trade partnership of
transatlantic partnership what about you
already Hindus dead from many sides the
left and right populous in Germany must
love prompt because he seems to love
everything they love which is to destroy
the transatlantic trade agreement and to
shake hands with Putin and talk to him
instead of telling to back off of
Eastern Europe so they must get along
great but and no and he really afford to
start a trade war with China well I can
he afford not to and and how would it
look you see you stumble into these
things the way we did in the 1920s
between the but in the interwar period
we stumbled into their rounds of
escalation that led to a trade war it's
pretty fragile the world economy right
now anyway I I mean our hope is that
that he backs off and that there's a lot
of pressure on him now I was gonna say
the bigger issue I think the more
frightening one is the NATO and Russia
aspect rather than trade because teacher
doesn't exist yet okay but he's more
interested in the trans-pacific trade
partnership for the moment that's the
one that the rallies that he brought up
and in NAFTA with Mexico and Canada so
we'll see that that's sort of a test
case T chip was dead already i think it
is not we won't know it's it's it's gone
because we didn't have
Susan Nieman so on relations with Europe
on the NATO allies one thing that Trump
has said is that you have to see
everything as a transaction he's written
this great book the art of the deal he
didn't write it he says we all his ghost
writer wrote the book part of the deal
and he says somebody who wants to get
somewhere including in politics has to
be ready to get up and walk away from
the table and essentially he's
threatened to do that visa V NATO so
what do you think is to be expected when
it really comes down to it then he
afford to send those NATO allies packing
look Melinda we are all in agreement
that nobody saw this coming none of us
talking heads none of us media
intellectuals none of us journalists
whatever I my own belief and it was
rather ironic for someone who came of
age in the Vietnam War era was that the
Pentagon was going to save us because
last spring a number of generals said
publicly which is outrageous under a
commander in chief Trump they would not
serve they would retire early okay so I
thought we're safe right at least
they're so let's start from the fact
that none of us got this one right and
that it's a bit early to start
predicting what will happen I think
however we can say something about what
ought to happen what I want to do I was
immensely happy to see annex Republican
use the word fascist in my statement I
said I'm durable with fascist analogies
but he's very dangerous told us he's
evil yeah yeah absolutely um and I think
we ought to really remember that Winston
Churchill in the early 30s praised
Hitler and the Nazis got a lot of
mileage out of it if a strong leader was
a good thing I think we need to not play
this play down how dangerous he is I
think the Chancellor's statement was
terrific superb yesterday and until last
September I was never a big supporter of
the Chancellor but I think she's um
she's acting on principle and her
statement about values was absolutely
correct I hope every European leader
follows her and that Europe as
hold those of us who are in the public
intellectual business keeps awake for
what comes next because we didn't know
this was going to happen so the
Chancellor's statement for those who did
not perhaps here at amongst our audience
essentially reminded all of us that
Germany and the u.s. have a close
partnership because of the shared values
that they have and reminded us that it
needs to continue on that basis subtle
tea and the genius of the statement is
there's a diplomatic affront embedded in
subtle language which is very merculian
she spelled out the values a reminder
and that's never happened before
reminded Donald waiting afar leader she
said and the values are respect for
human dignity for all people all races
all so it was a long list and it
basically she she read back to him his
campaign speeches I thought it was I him
what he needs to be respecting so let me
ask you this because we are coming to
the end of our time the question that we
posed in our title was Trump and Europe
partners or rivals she was reminding
Donald Trump that partnership needs to
be based on these shared values Stefan
Cousteau Vic what do you think where are
we heading some in the media have said
this represents the beginning of a new
era the Europe can no longer count in
the United States is it really so
drastic for the time being we have to
presume that because with somebody who
changes his mind twice a day to say the
least how can how can you predict what
the policies will be so Europe at least
for the time being probably has to at
least bank on going on its own and see
see what what's going to happen let's
not forget she was also speaking to
Europe she was both speaking to Donald
Trump and and it you know with a clarity
that you never see in diplomatic
statements but she was also speaking to
other Europeans so what do you think
partners arrivals going forward from
this point I think it very much depends
on
oh god it depends on a lot of things
that I that I don't think we can predict
but I think Europe has to be a bulwark
of these shared values and has to
recognize its responsibility understood
very briefly partnership rivalry or
something in new era we can't say
anymore that we're unambiguous partners
but I my hope is that that will prevail
that all the forces will turn him that
way thank you very much to all of you
for being with us and thanks to all of
you out there for tuning in see you soon